Let's have a look at
text alternative images.
We can use the old attribute to
provide a text alternative images.
However, we need to think about what
role an image plays in the page
to work out what type of text
alternative it should have.
Let's have another look at this
newspaper page from the previous lesson.
I've got VoiceOver running and
I'm going to use the mouse pointer
Moves VoiceOver Cursor option
to let me quickly inspect things for
VoiceOver.
Now, you probably don't want
this on all of the time.
But it can be good for
quickly testing things.
>> HTML content.
>> All right.
So here, we have a picture of a cat
illustrating that article on cats.
VoiceOver announces this has.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay, so that was pretty sub optimal.
I can pull up div tools on the image and
add an alt attribute which says a cat
staring menacingly off into space.
All right, so
now I can try VoiceOver again
>> VoiceOver on Chrome, HTML content,
a cat staring menacingly off into space.
>> And now you have a nice succinct
description of the image and
move on to the article.
A couple comments on the alt attribute.
Alt allows you to specify a simple
string to be used whenever an image is
not available, whether the image
fails to load like it has here or
you're a web crawling bot or a screen.
Alt differs from any other type
of caption, including a title,
in that it will only be used
if the image isn’t available.
Caption or title typically
provides extra context for
the image,
rather than an alternative to the image.
Writing useful alt text
is a bit of an art.
In order for a string to be a usable
text alternative it needs to convey
the same thing as the image
in the given context.
To give a more complex example, we have
that logo image in the masthead link.
That link is going to take
us back to the homepage.
So it might be tempting
to write home here.
That's not a functional
alternative to the image.
It's actually going to create
a more confusing experience,
because then we might get the idea that
it's an image of some kind of home.
Instead, we can describe this image
pretty accurately simply as The Funion.
You may or may not want to explicitly
call out that it's a logo, but
given it's an image, that's more or
less implied anyway.
An easy way to check whether
alt text is sensible,
is to imagine all your
images are broken.
Can you still understand
the page content?
Now there's one image I left in here
that I'd like to take a closer look at.
You have this magnifying glass logo,
inside the search link.
If I checked it out with the VoiceOver,
>> Magnifying
glass,
>> I can hear that we've hopefully
added an alt text of magnifying glass,
but if I inspect the link as a whole.
>> Magnifying glass search link.
>> We can hear that it
is actually redundant.
>> Magnifying glass search doesn't
convey anything that search doesn't.
How do we know that if we leave the alt
text out, we'll probably hear the image
file name which we already saw as
a potentially horrible experience.
So in this case, I'm going to
to use an empty alt text, and
we'll see what that does.
The empty alt text actually removed
the image from the accessibility tree
altogether, so the image is now
completely skipped by the screen reader.
In this case it's actually what we want,
because the image was redundant.